Okay, so we are talking about the Retarget Manager,
and I will dive right back into Unreal,
and let's take a look at the Infinity Blade Warriors
and go into the Character folder,
double-click on Complete Characters,
and there we have our different skeletal meshes,
our warrior people.
And I'm actually going to first rename the skeleton,
because if I show you the name of the skeleton
for the base character that's in the level right now,
and I click on the magnifying glass next to the skeletal mesh
in the Details panel, click on that, the name is very similar.
I can double-click on UE4 Mannequin Skeleton,
and we will use that later,
and I'll just keep that tab up at the top,
and then if I go back to Third Person Example Map,
go back to the Complete Characters folder,
let me just click on the SK Mannequin Skeleton, hit F2,
and let's change it to Warrior underscore Skeleton,
so that will be easier for me to keep track of,
and then any time you rename something,
any time you move something, any time you delete something,
it's a good idea to fix up the Redirectors,
so that Unreal is up to date,
and it's not accidentally pointing to something
that doesn't exist anymore,
and then I'm just going to right-click
on the Infinity Blade Warriors,
choose Fix Up Redirectors in the folder,
and let it do its thing,
and it's more applicable if I had already brought the assets
into the level, because there's more references,
but I just wanted to go ahead and show that to you,
so you've got it in your back pocket.
Okay, so Inside Character, Complete Characters,
double-click on the Warrior Skeleton,
and dock the tab up at the top.
Now, I'm going to switch over to the UE4 Mannequin Skeleton tab,
and I want to show you these sub-editors,
because Unreal Engine 4, it contains four major tools
for working with skeletal animations and skeletal meshes.
The Skeleton Editor, the Skeletal Mesh Editor,
the Animation Editor, and Animation Blueprint Editor,
and you can access all of them
by using the navigation breadcrumbs up at the top,
so I can double-click, and now I'm in the Skeletal Mesh section,
and I have a new tab, but I will close that for now,
because if we're dealing with the Retarget Manager,
I want you to think, okay, Skeletal Sub-Editor.
Now, if you don't have the Retarget Manager,
what you can do is go to Window,
and then find the Retarget Manager, click on that,
and then it will pop right up.
But first, let's look at the Skeletal Tree,
and then if I click on some of these bones,
and I can actually go up to Character, Bones,
and let's show the entire hierarchy for now,
so All Hierarchy. There we go, that's easier to see.
And I just want to point out that these finger bones
on the middle and the pinky, they actually do exist,
but they have zero influence on the mesh,
and that's why they're grayed out.
So I thought that was a clever way of using the exact same bone
structure with different functionality
by having different influences or lack of influences on the bones.
So really, only the index and this middle finger
are affecting this clump of finger geometry.
But let's get into the Retarget Manager,
so click on that tab,
and do you see this section that says Setup Rig?
This is what I mean by Bone Mapping Section,
and first thing you have to do is select the rig
and choose Humanoid Rig,
and that default is actually based on the exact same bone structure
in the base skeleton.
So if I look at this Skeleton Tree, you'll see, okay,
root, pelvis, spine one, two, etc.
If I go back to Warrior Skeleton,
look, it's the exact same thing in that Target column.
The Source column refers to the bones of the current character.
So what I'm going to do is hit Save up at the very top
and click on that,
and you might be tempted to click this Save button
that's in the Bone Mapping section,
but that will actually save the bone mapping to its own asset file,
and it's useful if you have a complex setup,
and then you can load it later,
and if your bones have different names,
you could try the Auto Map, and Unreal will do its best guess,
and then there's also the Show Advanced,
and that shows things like fingers and twist bones and IK bones,
things like that. So I will go back and click Show Base.
Okay, and you would think that we would be done,
and we did the bone mapping on one character,
so we should be able to move on to the next step,
but we actually have to go to UE4 Manic and Skeleton
and make sure that they are both talking to the bone mapping translator.
So I'm going to, again, select Humanoid Rig,
even though it's the exact same thing, right, and hit Save.
So now these characters can talk to each other,
but I want to be a little bit more precise
and make sure that the motion that gets transferred looks right.
So I will go to the Skeleton Tree,
and I'm going to do this for both characters,
and under Options, I will go to Show Retargeting Options,
and I want to double check and make sure that the root is set to Animation,
that Animation Scaled is chosen for Pelvis,
and then everything else should be Skeleton except for the IK bones.
Those could be set to Animation,
and what I'll do is I will click on the IK foot root
and right-click and recursively set that to Animation,
and then do that one more time for the IK hand root.
Okay, let's hit Save, and then I will explain what I just did.
Translation Retargeting
Now, Translation Retargeting, it's used to make sure that when we retarget,
the motion looks appropriate for the proportions of the character.
Now, for things like the root and IK bones,
you want it to listen strictly to the mocap data.
For everything except for the pelvis, usually,
you want the bone data to also take into account
the proportions of the current character,
not what was on the mocap data of the original person recording the motion.
And then Animation Scaled, it's a combination of the two,
and that way you can listen to the mocap data
and then multiply it by the difference in height of the pelvis.
So we've got that. Let's do the same on the Warrior Skeleton.
So I'm going to Skeleton Tree,
clicking Options, Show Retargeting Options,
leave the first one on Animation,
change Pelvis to Animation Scaled.
It looks like everything else is Skeleton and IK is already set to Animation.
Good. All right.
So let me save and I'll double check that I saved on the previous one.
All right. So step one
was to do the bone mapping.
Step two is to take care of the Skeleton Tree Translation Retargeting.
And then step three would be if the poses of our characters were different.
Okay. We would need to make sure that they are the same.
Otherwise, maybe the arms would be rotated too far one way or the other.
And you can click Modify Pose and find an asset loaded on there and then retarget.
But the pose is the same so we don't have to worry about that.
Okay. So let's do some retargeting.
Now there's two methods of retargeting.
One deals with retargeting animations.
The other has to do with telling the skeletal mesh to look at a different skeleton.
But for this section, we'll start with just retargeting the animations.
Now I'm going to go to my third person example map and I want to find an animation.
So under Mannequin Animations, let's do the third person run.
I will right click on it, go up to Retarget Anim Assets, Duplicate Anim Assets and Retarget.
Okay. Back in our slides, you'll notice a picture of a car.
Now this is just to remind you that this would never work.
So the bone mapping needs to be the same.
So that is just a reminder about that.
Okay. So I'm back in the Retarget Manager and look, our warrior skeleton.
It actually shows up. That's a good sign.
So I'm going to click on that.
I usually keep the retarget checkboxes set to default, but here's what I will do.
Rather than it being called a third person run, how about I change third person using
the replace functionality and change that to warrior underscore.
Or you could choose to have a prefix or a suffix.
And then rather than it being saved directly on the top folder level game,
same thing as content folder, I'm going to change that.
And let's create a new folder underneath Infinity Blade Warriors.
Let's right click on Infinity Blade Warriors.
Let's do a new folder and call it Animations.
And let's put it in there.
And hit okay.
So we've got a new path.
We changed the name so we don't get confused.
Let's hit retarget.
And then if I double click on Warrior run, ta-da, looking pretty snazzy.
Okay. And we've got the animation sub editor open.
I'm going to hit save.
And let me go back to third person example map.
And let's go back to our mannequin animations.
And you can actually retarget multiple animations at a time.
So let's do that.
We did the run.
So let me do a shift click and a control click.
So I've got everything except for the run.
Right click and retarget anim assets.
Duplicate anim assets and retarget.
Click on Warrior Skeleton.
Replace third person with Warrior underscore.
Change the folder directory to Infinity Blade Warriors animations.
Hit okay.
Retarget.
Okay. And then let's go to that folder.
So Infinity Blade Warriors animations.
We could double click on it from here or we could go back to the Warrior run tab.
And in the asset browser, we can click on other animations too.
Cool. So I'll hit save and I'll go back to third person example map and do a control shift S.
Save all.
So that was one way of retargeting.
I will show you another way in the next video.